ce temps sur karine le marchand qui a eu
des propos un peu un petit peu un petit
peu pas bien méchant mais elle s'est un
peu lâché sur tpb c'était dans les
grosses têtes
regardez les retours de jean luc lemoine
donc pas la grosse tête mais un peu dans
notre boîte et voilà on aimait bien
jean-luc la vue jean-luc faut être
rapide
donc je me caler sur toi oui tant pis là
s'est fâché hanouna ne faut pas dire du
mal à ça qu'elle n'a pas digéré
certaines choses non si il aime pas je
n'ai bien sûr mais c'est pas grave c'est
l'un des dossiers les mici j'aime bien
le moment pas les paysans à chaque fin
de mission j'ai envie de me taper un
agriculteur avait tombe bien je viens de
repiquer des poireaux allez bonne et les
bat on est agitée m
je vous le dis que j'ai totalement d'ici
pardon pardon vous dire que je vais en
parler au patron
il va à remontage de bretelles dès lundi
choqué parce que c'est n'importe quoi
j'ai pas breton arrêté dans le monde
gère mon avis de l a dit ce qu'elle
pense et ça c'est bien c'est pas très
violent c'est plus sympa elle a comme
petites piques jean-luc l'a très bien
pris
c'est le pays connaître exactement et
avec son humour et sa faconde ça passe
très bien donc oui j'aime ça alors la
faconde et là moi j'aime pas le risque
il ya un autre extrait sûr qu'il faut
s'amuser de leurs bourses et vous et des
propos très pas toujours très tendre sur
le medef elle appelle l'amour est dans
le pré ouais parlement non mais après
j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle pour vous
quoi c'est très embêtant parce qu'il ya
parce qu'il ya un agriculteur qui a
entendu ce qu'il avait dit ouais et le
mec c'est une armoire à glace way est
très en colère mais vous avez des propos
un petit peu déplacé concernant les
électeurs contre concernant l'émission
twitter lui oui lui voilà c'est surtout
non je tiens à informer le public
ces images des images peuvent choquer
mais au demeurant nous nous devons de
les diffuser pour des questions de ty
éthiques
regardez ça fait froid dans le dos est
ce que tu crois sincèrement que l'amour
est dans le pré est évoqué toi et
l'homme et je te le dire que le designer
marc génis si je donne tout surtout cela
qui manque au dernier si je trouve de
leur monde
là je me dois de répondre il jouait dans
ma tête oui à bingo tremblay mathieu
[Applaudissements]
réponse à regret que j'ai pas eu peur
parce que j'ai pas compris je soutenir
parce que d'abord c'est pages écrites
étaient les agriculteurs c'est comme si
je disais je quittais canaguy donc les
animateurs ouais je dis juste que et ce
monsieur n'a pas compris c'est dommage
que j'étais au contraire dans son sens
et qu'effectivement cette émission ben
on sur dix actions des agriculteurs on
en montre à en slip 42 d'ouvrir la porte
en slip 1 qui bourré inquiet rouge aux
incas pas dedans inquiet machin c'est
pas ça les agriculteurs caïla et moi et
on se moque pas d'eux on parce que les
séquences les victimes
c'est comme ça et c'est machin alors
arrêtez de faire croire que vous aimez
les agriculteurs vous vous foutez leur
gueule dans une émission de télé réalité
on n'est pas de moi là trois enfants
voilà donc ce monsieur je ne défend plus
tôt et je lui dis tu as un beau métier
que tu es en train de mettre
malheureusement mauvaise lumière
oui la réponse pas laisser dire ça parce
que justement l'amour est dans le pré
c'est formidable pour ça parce qu'on
découvre ce métier là ces hommes là et
il ya plein de portraits on s'attache au
personnage peut pas dire qu'on se moque
d'eux c'est pas vrai à vous voir à
valenciennes massif entamé 15 puisqu'il
ou elle apporte chez jeanne mas il a le
droit étranger et donc il y avait
normalement un pantalon le producteur et
policiers chargés à londres et j'ai aimé
chez je suis pas sûr qu effectivement
ils sont à mon avis un peu de plus en
plus dans la caricature